it's the mission of the century a daring
rescue into the depths of one of the
most dangerous locations in the
multiverse
site 13 otherwise known as scp-1730 when
the impossible site 13 was first
discovered
multiple mobile task forces were sent to
plummet's depths and none returned
they were greeted to a labyrinthine
nightmare littered with deadly
cognitohazards escaped scps
and mysterious murderous leeches some
were trapped along with the civilians
they were sent to rescue
others were killed or changed in
unimaginable ways
mobile task force apollo 3 also known as
the game wardens had been sent in on a
rescue mission when they encountered a
horrifying sight
the captured broadcast of bobble the
clown a dangerous scp known for
corrupting and destroying children
through its deadly messages
but this bubble was different much like
everything from site 13 this bottle
came from an entirely different
dimension and he had terrifying
information to relay
in the universe where scythe 13
originated the site's psychopathic
director one elliot emerson had struck a
deal with the global occult coalition
a controversial government group who
intends to protect humanity by killing
anomalies rather than containing them
emerson had converted his site into an
unethical unrestrained slaughterhouse
and was incinerating scps by the hundred
in the so-called body pit
but emerson's game of death came back
and bit him snapping the threads of
reality and turning the entire site into
a dimensionally displaced super anomaly
the game wardens realized they were in
way over their heads
their chances of surviving this place
were dropping by the second and if they
wanted any chance of succeeding in their
mission they needed
backup so site command called in mtf
tau5
aka samsara calling in samsara for a
run-of-the-mill collection mission
is like using a bazooka to kill a
housefly but for a case as severe
1730 their skills were not only nice to
have but
vital samsara are among the best of the
best immortal cybernetic clones forged
from the flesh of a god
equipped with weaponry and technology
that could surpass even that of other
elite mobile task force units
the four members of samsara are so adept
at what they do they earned the nickname
power rangers among their peers the
remaining game wardens knew that with
samsara on the case
they may actually survive this thing
after all and they just needed to hold
out
samsara arrived on site not long after
packing some serious technological heat
including arm mounted incendiary cannons
shock absorbing leg extensions
heat resistant plating and built-in
scramble adaptations within their eyes
to ward off the deadly cognito hazards
everyone involved was in for the fight
of their lives the four samsara agents
irantu nanku munru
entered via a drainage gate in one of
the office buildings above ground and
began their descent inside
after observing numerous chart bodies
they deduced that there must have been a
massive incinerator somewhere on site
emerson's incinerator theorizing that
this was connected to the body pit they
kept hearing about
they descended further feeling the
temperature rise as they did so
due to the anomalous nature of 1730
nothing inside made any kind of logical
sense
caused by a reality warping machine
known as thresher
the internal geography of site-13 was
subject to constant shifts
the team then split up to cover more
ground moonro and nanku continued to
follow the pipes
and the heat toward the furnace while
irantu and onru broke away to explore
what lay beyond
a weak wall after busting through the
wall irantu and onru explored several
empty office blocks before finding their
way into a control room with a glass
observation deck while the window was
obscured by garbage and human corpses
signage indicated that the incinerator
and the body pit were directly below
them
the team once again reconvened and
managed to activate the incinerator
which shredded the mass stuck inside
with several large turbines before
burning the resulting slurry
the same process that had happened to so
many anomalies under emerson's
watch with the path cleared samsara
decided to descend via the incinerator
using the drainage pipe as a kind of
makeshift tunnel eventually they
happened upon the leeches
large black and hungry these creatures
seemed to infect
1730 by the thousand anywhere that blood
or drainage runoff could be found
the leeches could be found too they
didn't appear to have any connection to
an anomaly previously secured and
contained by the foundation
they squeezed and wriggled through the
cracks in the walls searching for fresh
blood
on root detected that the leeches all
moved with a kind of collective purpose
suggesting a telepathic hive mind onru
was able to tap into this hivemind using
her cybernetic enhancements
and mapped the chaotic geography of 1730
through the leech colony's collective
knowledge
with this new advantage they could add a
second goal to this rescue mission
find the thresher device causing all the
instability and potentially reduce power
to it if possible
but they were on the clock to save the
other survivors as those leeches were
sure to get
hungry for warm blood soon they followed
the leeches down the most direct
path toward the survivors on the way
they encountered a horrifying creature
the many limbed humanoid nightmare that
functions as emerson's eternal
punishment his charred body tied
screaming and alive to the platform
where the monster's head should be
they managed to make it past the monster
before finally rendezvousing with
captain hollis of mobile task force
satan ix
otherwise known as the mole rats as well
as the game wardens and the other
survivors there were 27 surviving
members of site-13 staff
many of which had severe injuries making
it even harder to transport them back to
safety through the hazardous terrain
and to make matters worse the leeches
were back the team quickly decided that
the best route out of here was directly
past the thresher
where they could reduce power to the
machine for just long enough to create a
stable path of escape
nanku opened fire on a horde of
approaching leeches with a flamethrower
and everyone began running for their
lives
it was a final make or break dash to
safety however their advance was soon
stopped by a strange roped creature
drawing a cognito hazardous meme on the
wall with its claws
when the team attempted to engage it
attacked exposing additional deadly
memes and the dangerous effects of its
single white eye
and we're not talking about internet
memes here these are symbols and
information that are often deadly to
even bear witness to
and for uri this would be a real threat
but not to a team equipped with goggles
containing cognito hazard filter
technology
the battle was cut short when the floor
collapsed underneath them and the
creature was devoured by something even
larger and more monstrous
a gigantic black bleach covered in huge
red eyes
its entrance caused thousands of leeches
to spill out into the hall
as the monster screeched and slithered
its tentacles after them
allow us to introduce you to elijah also
known as the leech boy
and a pivotal component of the very
existence of scp-1730 he was a boy with
the mind of a toddler but he had the
strange ability to absorb blood through
people's skin
hence his nickname leechboy one of the
doctors in site 13 dr hadley took
pity on elijah after all he didn't
choose to be the way he was
director emerson didn't share hadley's
sympathy his orders to exterminate all
anomalies included humanoids like elijah
when hadley protested emerson had her
beaten within an inch of her life
while other dissenters were shot dr
hadley disgusted by the inhumanity of
her superiors
devised the perfect revenge she
sabotaged the incinerator and the body
pit
allowing a mass containment breach that
flooded the site with deadly anomalies
young elijah ended up consuming the
slurry of the other shredded anomalies
causing him to mutate into a powerful
monster
a behemoth of a leach who gave birth to
and controlled all the others
it was hadley's revenge that caused
emerson to panic and activate thresher
leading to a rift in reality in the
creation of 1730
and by extension all the problems faced
by our heroes today
samsara and the others fled leach boy
and began taking a different escape
route
however while on route they encountered
the dreaded crystal butterflies a
dangerous scp capable of destroying
organic matter with a mere touch
irantu stepped up to bat roasting the
creatures with his arm mounted
incinerator and taking
extreme damage to his body in the
process but they didn't have time to
rest with the butterflies disposed of
they kept moving
heading toward the thresher but not all
the scps were necessarily working
against them
bobble the clown came in handy at the
next checkpoint manifesting in the
monitor of an electronic door
and opening the way through as they
continued on their journey they had to
fight off frequent attacks from leeches
losing some of the task force members in
the process they were also forced to
face off against a number of other
anomalies in order to survive
such as scp-2316 manifesting his
floating bodies beneath them
and scp-1370 which used a huge
mechanized body to attack the team of
survivors
that was all just a warm up for the true
final battle though
the floor shattered beneath them and out
of an impossibly huge chamber the
monster that had once been elijah
wriggled free
reaching for them with huge tentacles
and shrieking from its thousand-toothed
maw
it was at least 200 meters tall and
barely reacted to any amount of
firepower
it seemed like they were all doomed
until captain hollis had a truly crazy
idea with the help of samsara she led
the bloodthirsty abomination down
through the cryonic center
and into an olympia class testing
chamber there as the leech boy was
bearing down on them hollis opened the
gates to two adjacent containment cells
and something beyond incredible happened
two of the most powerful scps ever known
a giant sword-wielding gate guardian and
the reality-bending cosmic deer scp-2845
entered the arena what followed was one
of the most epic showdowns in the
history of the scp foundation
as the deer and the gate guardian went
to battle against the all-devouring
leech
while the monsters fought hollis ordered
her team to get the rest of the
survivors to safety
she and moonroof of the samsara team
remained behind to prevent any of the
anomalies from escaping
as the entire base began sinking into
the ground from the combined forces of
the battle raging around them
and the threshers continued onslock on
reality even if the survivors escaped
would the anomalous developments inside
site 13 escape and wreak havoc on the
world at large
that's when hollis received a vision a
horrific charred post-apocalyptic world
roamed by inconceivably powerful
entities and nightmare gods
it was a vision so horrific that just
seeing it nearly broke her mind
she knew what she had to do the only way
she could truly defeat this terrible
place and ensure
safety for mankind while leech boy the
gate guardian and the deer continued
their battle for the ages
hollis ran to thresher and forced the
machine into overdrive
up above the remaining members of
samsara the mole rats and the game
wardens escorted the survivors to safety
downstairs thresher emitted a blinding
white light as the system began
overload in her final moments all hollis
could do was
laugh perhaps it was a laugh of pure
insanity of a mind broken by the horror
she witnessed
or perhaps it was a laugh of victory
knowing that in spite of the immense
powers all around her she had won the
day
she had saved not only the survivors and
her teammates but possibly
all of humanity and all it cost her was
everything
outside the survivors had reached a safe
distance away when the entirety of site
13
imploded in a final brilliant flash when
the dust cleared scp-1730 was gone
all that was left was an immense crater
where the impossible base should have
once been
captain hollis had done it through
overloading the thresher machine she'd
taken this anomaly out of the world the
exact same way it had entered
it was torn from its moorings on our
earth and kicked into the infinity of
space-time perhaps never to be seen
again
along with everything it contained
scp-1730 was reclassified to neutralized
of course the foundation would have
plenty of other anomalies to pursue soon
after
but the nightmare of emerson site 13 was
over once and for all
[Music]
you